i'm rich farwana again from microsoft
research this is the second presentation
in our session on the interpretable uh
interpretability for biological systems
happy to introduce jack gallant uh
jack is from here at berkeley where he's
the chancellor's professor in the
department of psychology
but he's also got affiliations in like
every other department in the university
electrical engineering computer science
neuroscience bioengineering vision
science and biophysics um
jack's research uh is in cognitive and
human neuroimaging and he's one of the
main people in neuroscience who's
focused on what you might think of as
naturalistic uh experiments that are
aimed at producing quantitative behavior
and models that are really accurate and
generalized well
um jack is very proud of the fact that
his lab really sweats the details when
it comes to data science um and that
they use an empirical workflow that's
actually quite different from the
standard approaches that are used
elsewhere in neuroscience so go ahead
take it away jack thank you
um i just want to um
let's see first of all i am i'm a
neuroscientist you know i do a lot of
applied math but that's kind of forced
it's not my desire i just really want to
do neuroscience
but because our data sets tend to be
more complicated than most people's in
my field um we've you know
we've paid very close attention to the
developments in data science over the
last 20 years
and so um i'm i i would say i have
glancing familiarity and uh sort of
empirical experience with a lot of these
methods
um
i did want to mention that you know the
last talk we just saw was awesome it was
an
amazing display of discovery science
driven by enormous infinitely large data
sets and great machine learning and this
talk's going to be the exact opposite of
that so
so this is going to be
depressing in some ways
that means it won't be a great talk
that that too
wasn't a mention i was thinking of but
that may be also true um okay so i just
want to mention because we were just
yesterday there was a lot of kind of
philosophical discussions about data
science i just wanted to mention you
know my perspective on this is
the the the deal here is that the
incentive structure for scientists is
very different than the incentive
structure for engineers in some sense
you know we all are doing the same thing
we want to measure some stuff
we want to build a model of the stuff
whose dimensionality is far lower than
the measurements right because then we
can understand it and then we want to
predict some new stuff
now if you're a scientist this is the
most important thing modeling the stuff
for the low dimensional model
and in fact it's so important in
i would say less developed areas of
science like psychology and biology and
neuroscience that people don't even
worry about this
there's no journal in psychology or
biology that i am aware of that requires
you to report predictions or effect size
or generalization tests
or even to have separate fit and test
data sets
um so everybody cares about this and
there and the them you know the mark is
statistical significance even though
that's the noise floor not the noise
ceiling and everybody reports
significance and they declare victory
and pretend it's noise ceiling and move
on
so that's that's science engineering
i think to its credit has to worry about
this whole thing because ultimately if
you have a statistically significant
bridge and it falls down you have a
problem and someone will sue you so the
lawyers keep the engineers honest and at
some point
they have to be able to predict
now every engineering professor in this
room knows that ideally you want this
you want a model that you can prove i
want to know the bounds when it'll work
when it won't work and then i want to
show that you know predict something
right
but of course the kids think this is
boring anybody under 25 wants to do this
because it's so much cooler and you can
get a job at facebook so they want to
build neural networks this engineering
professors hate this because you can't
prove anything with this when does it
work when does it not work i don't know
so this is kind of a stop gap
but if you don't know what to do here
like you've got a non-dynamical system
or something else that's mathematically
intractable
then this is the best you can do
and i think you know this morning as i
said sorry uh the talk that we just saw
was a great demonstration that this is
not a pointless exercise
but
these two points of view are very
different
engineering professors are willing to do
this because they've got to get here
first they've got to get to predictions
and they're willing to take a lousy
model first to get to predictions and
then go back and try to figure it out
and in in neuroscience this kind of deep
network model is
kind of pointless
um unless you can interpret it very very
quickly
so just wanted to mention so kind of a
very different thing very different
approach
all right so i study the brain
the brain is you know complicated that's
the first law of neuroscience
there's 80 billion neurons they're
organized in these very complicated
hierarchical parallel networks
um they're organized at multiple scales
the scales don't necessarily communicate
with one another they're kind of
compartmentalized
the brain connections are many too many
and recurrent
uh
the information that's flowing through
the brain networks is very very dynamic
and changes
based on the task and over time with
learning
uh and the brain learns continuously at
uh all time skills so
you know the brain is very different
than the deep networks we use in
computer science
those deep networks for the most part
are kind of i would say circa 1945
neuroscience
and neuroscience although it's very hard
we've learned a lot since that time and
most of that has not been incorporated
into
deep networks
uh but the real problem for a
neuroscientist trying to understand the
brain is this
we are data limited
at any point in time in any field of
science you're either model limited i
would say theory limited or you're data
limited neuroscience is data limited
it's always been data limited you're
probably data limited for a long time
and if you want to think of if you don't
know anything about neuroscience but you
know perhaps about physics the way to
think about neuroscience is it's like
astrophysics with a really bad telescope
so
you all know the problems with
astrophysics there's billions of stars
out there you can see
a few thousand maybe um it's the same
problem in neuroscience
and in fact i've had tons of physicists
come through my lab the only ones that
stick around are the astrophysicists
because they just look at the data
they're like oh this is the same kind of
lousy data i always deal with no problem
so um
the brain on a very short time scale of
say a half an hour is a fixed network
the hardware doesn't change but the
information flowing through the network
changes uh based on
attention and learning and the test
demands
through these control signals that are
broadly distributed and no one really
understands so the representation of
information the brain is constantly
dynamically evolving
uh
in the human brain we don't really know
exactly what the hardware is we don't
know all the brain errors there's
probably something like 500 at least
different brain structures that all
represent different kinds of information
in this deep network
and we don't have a very good idea of
how these networks represent information
so you can imagine if you take a
complicated task like uh driving um
while you're driving through the world
um there are
constantly changing patterns of brain
activity so you saw when i first put
this slide up that we put some slices in
the brain and kind of flattened it out
so now we have something about the size
of a large pizza and the red regions are
locations where metabolic activity is
higher than average and the blue regions
are locations where metabolic activity
is lower than average we're measuring
this with an mri machine
so you can see that these patterns of
red and blue are constantly changing
dynamically as uh an individual is
driving through
this virtual town in this taxi driver
task
sure
red here is more metabolic activity and
blue is less metabolic activity
this is what the person saw in so this
is an mri experiment
and the person's lying in the mri
machine and they're driving in this
virtual world and the brain is really
the brain of the person and this is the
brain oh wow yeah yeah this is real this
is real time
and um
uh i took that slide out this is an
awesome experiment they're actually
driving they've got a little steering
wheel in the mri machine game they've
got pedals and they've got the virtual
reality uh and a very complicated jury
rigged system on their eyes and um this
is a very large town it's about four
square miles on this side it's got about
200 structures and roads they spend
about 10 hours learning the town
and then after they've learned the town
we just put them in an uber driver task
drive to the taco bell and they drive to
the taco bell now drive to the gas
station that's all they do we do that
for hours and we record brain activity
okay
and then the question is well so think
about what you do when you when you're
doing this task okay you got to look at
the visual input right so that has to be
represented somewhere you got to operate
the pedals in the steering wheel that
stuff has to be operated it has to be
represented somewhere you have to know
where you're going you have to have some
memory of where you've been where you're
going what the map is
and if you notice in this road there's
other cars and vehicles and things you
have to avoid the other cars you can't
run into them can't run to the
pedestrians
there's traffic signals there's all
kinds of complicated things going on all
that stuff
the past the future perception motor
cognition all of it has to be
represented somewhere
in this
right and we want to know what and where
all right so uh so how do you solve this
problem do you always recall where the
muscles movements are
the muscle movements yeah yeah yeah we
have all the we have all the ground
truth from this so this is a video game
so we can extract all the semantic
information from the video game we know
where all the buildings are we know
where the cars are we know the layout of
the world
we uh
we track your eyes so we know where
you're looking and we're recording all
the motor movements so we know what your
behavior is so we have all the stimulus
task which is where you're going and
motor response variables those are our x
variables
and our y variables
are brain recordings from say 100 000
points in the brain this is a three test
mri machine records about 100 000 points
the new mri machine we're building here
at berkeley we'll get a hundred times
more data we'll get a million points
would be really cool
um so uh so that's that's basically our
data set there's a bunch of x's and
there's a bunch of y's yes what is the
frequency or temporal resolution
oh you don't want to know um so mri
i should just mention mri is the
greatest non-invasive imaging method
ever developed it just beats every other
method like eg and anything else to heck
it still sucks
the resolution of mri the tempo
resolution is about a second there's
almost no information
in the mri signals
at a time scale faster than one second
and that's because mri measures changes
in uh metabolic activity that are
reflected in oxygen flow in the blood
vessels
and the coupling between neural activity
neuron can fire about 100 times a second
and blood changes in blood flow blood
oxygenation is very very slow
yes can you make the town busier
yes this is just happens to be a sunday
morning so yeah yeah we can we there
there are other conditions where there's
some pedestrians crossing over and
here i presume you'll tell us later but
presumably you have more than one
subject
and how consistent
is this um
i'll show you in just a second but um
all the workflow in our lab is is like
again i don't do anything like anybody
else in neuroscience does it we never do
things at the group level what we do is
we do the whole experiment in each
individual subject
level but the same experience yeah i'll
show you in a second
so um okay so we got some x variables we
got some y variables that means we've
got a regression problem and you know
most neuroscience problems end up being
regression problems
so uh okay fine we're gonna do a
regression problem
you say regression you mean linear
regression
well that's the question what kind of
regression do we want to use right okay
some form of regression okay
so
what
supervised
well yeah i mean it could be it could be
it could be a network right so that's
that's the issue is what should we do
it's going to be a regression problem of
some form some very general form we've
got some x's we want to predict some y's
right
so
so traditionally the way you do this is
basically you just use you know your
standard
progression framework for doing this
you interpret as bayesians but you
implement it just as a standard glm
now if you do a linear model the brain's
highly non-linear so this would be kind
of dumb and wouldn't get you very far
so uh generally what we do in my lab i'd
say 95 of the work is this linearized
model which is basically we take the
stimulus task and motor variables and we
shove them through some complicated
computational model
that is meant to
produce
an intermediate representation that we
think might exist somewhere in the brain
and then we regress that representation
onto the brain data and as long as the
brain as long as everything's stationary
that should always work because you can
always stick a linearity at the end of
any arbitrary non-linear system and it's
the same system
right if the brain's non-stationary
you're screwed but let's not think about
that because
we're all screwed all the time
that's non-stationarity is bad okay so
generally we do this and i'll explain
how we do this in a minute of course
like i said all the kids want to do this
let's just stick a neural network in
here and even if you want to do this you
can neural network in here there are
multiple ways to do it that all have all
their own dis advantage and
disadvantages
um so uh generally this is our
linearized regression framework
essentially we have um
we have usually multiple feature spaces
that we're testing simultaneously in
this driving experiment we actually have
33 different kinds of feature spaces to
33 different models we want to fit them
all simultaneously they all have their
own signals noise they all have
different signals noise and different
brain regions so we use essentially a
banded ridge regression model that
allows us to
estimate different regularizers for each
of these different feature spaces and
they all get fit simultaneously
so this kind of gives you an idea we got
our simultan task we have our brain
activity we've got our limit we've got
some linearizing feature space that
we're going to
interpose between these two because
they're too non-linear to each other we
can pick a variety of feature
spaces uh and then we're gonna have some
training data some testing data
sorry some some train data some train
features
uh we're gonna get some model weights
and then we're gonna cross-validate when
i held that data set are you doing
single voxel or you're doing join model
um in this stuff i'll be talking about
we're doing one voxel at a time
um i'm a strong believer in starting at
the finest green first and then working
your way up i don't like averaging
anything until i absolutely have to so
this is all single voxel
i i really hate averaging optimal
averaging is great all other averaging
sucks and i hate throwing away
information so i don't like to average
without knowing what i'm doing
okay and then we're going to test
basically on you know
a variety of statistical tests because
if we don't do significance testing um
the psychologists will complain
uh generally we uh produce a variety of
metrics in these experiments yeah we do
statistical significance we don't really
care about that what we really care
about is estimating the noise ceiling
and then what fraction of the noise
ceiling we're performing in other words
how good is our prediction performance
um
so now where do you get these features
in
yes
so uh they don't have to be right you
can the features can be whatever you
want and you can label them post talk
so um
and because you're doing something
post-talk you might worry well wait a
minute you're just gonna over fit
so in our lab not only we have separate
fit and test data sets
uh to prevent overfitting and then
within the fifth set and break that up
into separate training and test sets for
exploratory data analysis we also
collect separate fit and test subjects
so we'll like say collect three subjects
get all the models finalized okay this
is it we're freezing everything and then
we'll just fit in the other three
subjects to make sure we get the same
results
yeah um
so you're the input to this model is it
a single still image
no no the input of the model is the
video data okay so you're you're feeding
in like
you're trying to like how like it's
as much as as much as the individual
feature spaces need okay like you might
have a model that says i think there's
gonna be somewhere in the brain that
represents where you started from
throughout the entire trip it knows
where you started from and that
representation's gonna be active that's
a theory i have so i can set a feature
space that will that is just basically
where you started from and it will
integrate over all time or it will be
tested at all time points right features
basically anything and of course there's
gonna be a bunch of feature space that
have to do with prospective planning
about where you're gonna drive and a
bunch of feature space is gonna be
involved with retrospection and memory
about where you were in the past
okay so uh so now we need to we need to
get some features where do we get the
features from well we can get up you
know first off you can you can just
guess what the features might be like
probably you know where the buildings
are the stop signs and the people that
are wandering around there and you can
get them from the video game data
because i have the subject view i can do
a semantic segmentation i know where
you're fixating so i know what you're
attending to i can get all kinds of
features this would just be semantic
features from this right but i also have
optical flow i have color i have all the
behavioral data
and so this actually just shows the
results of one feature space which is
semantic segmentation this game absence
gives you 16 categories of features and
you can color code them according to pca
of the features and then kind of plot on
us on a flat map and this is how we
interpret things this is basically our
final data is always
feature spaces projected onto the
cerebral cortex and we flatten it out
because we want to see the whole thing
and this uses a software developed in my
lab
all right so this is the this is a
really like i'm just glossing over so
much information here so don't worry
about it this is 33 models that we fit
you can see there's path distance
remaining how far do you have to go your
future path you're going to take the b
line distance remaining the controls you
used
uh
um
day semantics affordances which is where
can you drive where you can't where
can't you drive motion energy spatial
semantics there's all kinds of stuff
going on here all everything we could
think of based on the literature that
might be represented in the brain during
navigation
this comes from huge amounts of animal
and human literature we put all these
models simultaneously all at once in one
subject
and
now of course you've got too much data
because all together
there's 33 feature spaces here but the
number of features here is about
somewhere probably around 40 000
features and we're fitting that to each
of 100 000 voxels so it's a big data
fitting problem
um we use kernel ridge regression for
this because the time axis is very very
short so colonel ridge regression
enables us to solve this fitting problem
even though
you know
you shouldn't be able to
and um then then we get all these data
we have too much data to think about so
we have two dimensional reduction
everybody does the same thing when you
do dimensional reduction you either do
pca or cluster analysis or something
right those are just two sides of the
same coin
and so you get about five different
networks when you do this this happens
to be a tsm which i'm not a big fan of
but that's what that's what's shown here
you get uh future navigation motor
visual motor visual inputs which is what
you see
and pass navigation
of dimensionality reduction that you're
using i mean it is i'm just showing you
one example here okay obviously we do pc
we're going to get a different result
than tsme or
or non-negative matrix factorization
whatever the heck you want to do right
and so um generally we do multiple
things there's no right thing to do so i
was taught when i was a graduate student
by my very wise old advisor if there's
no right thing to do do it as many wrong
ways as possible and see if the results
you get are consistent that's generally
my philosophy
um so this just kind of shows you you
know the data are rich and high
dimensional
you can also do pca so if you do pca on
these data which you know is just a
different meta dimensional direction you
get kind of three functional networks a
motor network a visual network and a
navigation network okay you should all
at this point go duh because you know if
i asked you beforehand before i show you
this data what would the three
subdivisions be that's probably what
you'd pick but now the cool thing is we
can kind of see where they're located
across the cerebral cortex you know this
is three subjects
um these networks are fairly consistent
with each other
yes
how do you know the first one is motor
and not the second or the third
um
you what you do is after you get the pc
you have to look and see what it's
loading on
right so it's loading on the controls
also
this happens to be where your motor
system is located and this is where your
visual system is located in
i just want to mention this was only the
first five minutes of the talk so wait
what
yeah the next one no no continue
yeah we'll have an hour afterwards so
yeah it's probably with me you know i'm
a professional i'll talk to tomorrow
so how do you know we should carry your
first pc map
uh well again you have a you have um you
take the principal components
and so each voxel has a projection of
pcs
so now uh if you just take the first
three pcs um you can assign them to the
red green and blue gun and then you can
sign that box with a color of its
projection in this first three pc space
it's just a quick and dirty way to
try to
see where things lie
but this is on the input x
that's the part the pc is a dimensional
reduction on a matrix that's boxes by
feature worlds the future you know
it's our regression it's our regression
matrix that we're pc you have the volume
right yeah boxes by weights
so this is 100 000 by fifty thousand
same matrix
and get one of those matrices for each
subject
right so usually when you wanna when you
get these pcs what you do is you stack
the matrices all together so you're
getting pcs for all the
subjects you
don't have to do that handy thing to do
all right these these subjects are
pretty consistent
uh now
what neuroscientists really want to know
is which model is important and which
model's not important and in the
regression framework that ends up being
basically a variance partitioning
game that you have to play and we all
know that variance partitioning works
great if you have three variables and
then it all breaks down and goes to hell
don't worry about that please don't ask
me any questions pretend that the
there's no real weird wizard behind the
curtain and just like go with it this is
kind of the variance partitioning scheme
uh for these different variables you can
see that some things like affordances
where can you drive
future path where am i going to go in
the
future steering and controls
um
well this is other models that's not it
um motion energy which is low level
visual features
um gay semantics which is what is the
semantic category the thing you're
looking at these are most of the
variables that account for most of the
variants
and sadly all the variables that people
who do navigation uh research actually
care about which are these very subtle
kinds of navigation related feature
spaces they account for a vanishingly
small fraction of the variance
and i think that's just you know those
variables are really important
but
they're only important for a subset of
brain areas some of those brainers like
the hippocampus tend to be very far away
from the antennas and our mri machine
and therefore have low signals and noise
so they don't end up contributing very
much
are these directions orthogonal they're
not exactly talking about these these
models are not orthogonal at all
that's why variance prediction is kind
of a tricky it's a fraught exercise
with with uh any complicated data set
like this but you got to do something
right
so you know it's kind of funny this talk
this uh meeting is about
interpreting deep learning models but if
you think about this fitting 33 feature
spaces just using the glm
we we don't even know how to interpret
those data
so and that's like you know a 200 year
old method right so
kind of scary
um i should also mention that uh
as i said these brain representations
are not static they're dynamic if you go
home tonight and your cat fluffy that's
all of a sudden missing your brain tries
to become a giant fluffy detector where
is fluffy where is fluffy every place in
your brain tries as hard as it can to be
optimized for the fluffy detection task
and brain areas like near your visual
system your primary visual cortex they
don't change very much they're just
going to keep
signaling the outside world with your
prefrontal cortex every neuron will get
sucked into this fluffy detection
enterprise and will become a giant
fluffy detector
and that's just how the brain works it's
this dynamic network that reconfigures
its representation based on the task and
you can see that here
when you're in this driving task this is
basically a neutral driving state versus
a task directed driving state
a bunch of representations shift towards
poles which are where the traffic
signals are
sidewalks and other vehicles
and traffic signs which are all the
things you need to pay attention to in
this task
okay so fine
does that does that experiment me happy
no
why not
well okay it's like the most massive
experiment is done on a data set like
this but it um we're only we're only
accounting for like no no 50 percent of
the
variance we have in the data so there's
a bunch of other signal that we should
be able to model and i don't know what
those feature spaces are
so as i said if you're under 25 your
first thought is why don't use a neural
network train drive in this environment
and then you'd solve all the problems
so
there's a long history of people trying
to use neural networks in neuroscience
to explain data in fact the very first
paper ever that used a neural network
which is a three-layer neural network in
the good old days um to directly fit to
neural data was from young dan who's
here at uc berkeley
and um her students uh brian lau and her
postdoc here at stanley and a few years
later we did the same thing this is a
pretty simple enterprise you've got some
neural data that you collected you just
try to basically train your neural
network by backprop and then
the models will fit really well if you
have enough data and then you try to
interpret them and of course by to
interpret them you have to project them
into some space that means something
right
and that's fine you can do this but
this is never going to work with the
data sets we have because we're data
limited we'd never have enough data to
fit a full neural network so although in
some ways this might be a great thing to
do it's out of the possibility of things
we can do
so that's useless
so what people do in this field for the
most part
is they use a pre-trained neural network
train on a different task and they take
the features from that network and then
they use the glm to fit into their data
and that's a lot better because now the
network has learned something that might
be useful and you can figure out what in
the learn network is useful for you
so uh in the vision world where this has
been applied
in the vision world that uh where this
is done
no that's not what's done usually
because
people who are doing neuroscience don't
view themselves in the business of
training networks right so they'll take
the networks from another source so for
example you'll take alexnet or you'll
take vgg
and you'll use the features trained in
those networks which are all trained on
static images and you'll use those
features to fit your data
and those models actually do a pretty
good job um the first person who did
this recently the kind of the recent you
know post
post three layer network world um was
jim carlos group at mit and they showed
that these
uh models do a good job of predicting
neural responses to natural images
across a wide range of the visual
hierarchy
so this is a perfectly good thing to do
um we've also done this
this is a study from a former student of
of um that spent some time in my lab
used to tender students now a professor
at mit polk at agrawal and he used um
alexnet actually to fit voxels in the
early visual system so the visual assist
these are all the early visual areas
early intermediate visual areas in the
early visual hierarchy and uh what he
found is that different layers of
alexnet fit different locations in the
visual hierarchy
i thought this was a boring result
because to me it's obvious the brain is
a hierarchical network
trained to represent natural images so
it's going to represent the hierarchical
statistics natural images
alexnet is a hierarchical network
trained to represent natural image so
it's going to represent the hierarchical
cisco natural images
the interesting result would be if those
things weren't the same right
the fact they're the same just means
they learn the same thing and that to me
doesn't that interesting but everybody
else got very excited about this
there are some problems using the
networks in this way mainly that the
layers of deep networks
are very very highly correlated with one
another unless you take care to decorate
them and basically nobody tries to do
that so uh but what you can do is you
can use banded ridge regression to fit
the individual layers of neural networks
uh separately and banded ridge
regression will essentially
do
it will adjudicate between the different
correlated layers and it will select the
appropriate layer for each voxel and
this kind of cleans up your data line
this kind of an ongoing
line of research in our lab it's how to
use neural networks to get a fairer
answer about what is being represented
in the brain that's not contaminated by
the biases in the neural networks
themselves
okay but the in the last part of the
talk which i'll try to make quick
um i want to talk about another approach
to using neural networks and deep
learning that nobody's mentioned yet and
that is
using the really great infrastructure
for fitting deep networks
to fit an architected neural network
that is bespoke for your purposes
so um i have long for like the last 40
years studied this visual area
called area v4 it's in the middle of the
visual hierarchy in the old days you
know when we had
poorer methods you can only study one
area at a time couldn't study the whole
brain so i started setting v4 and
there's no good model of v4
it's a really important intermediate
visual area there's no computational
model of v4 that does any good at all so
we uh
we tried to solve that problem and we
tried to solve it by recording from
single b4 neurons um for weeks and
months
so by doing that this gave us a data set
that was far far larger than anybody
else's data set so rather than having
say you know 10 minutes of
stimulus response
histograms for a neuron we would have
say four hours of data from a single
neuron and over several years we
collected data from 300 neurons in two
animals and that was that was data sets
you know 100 times bigger than any other
data set out there
for this area so then we said okay now
we want to fit neural networks we still
don't have enough data to just fit a
general neural network and plus then we
would have an interpretation problem
so instead let's try to fit an
architected neural network that's
designed to reflect
mechanisms computational mechanisms in
the visual system that we know exist
so that turns out to be this thing here
this is a cascade
we begin by taking our stimuli and doing
a log polar transform on them and that's
because your primary visual cortex does
a log polar transform on the retinal
image
to emphasize the phobia
then
we already know we have really good
models in neuroscience for primary
visual cortex this is an area that's
been studied for 60 years they're really
good models for this they're used all
the time in computer vision it's the
motion energy model
so v1 we implement a motion energy model
using neural network architecture a deep
network architecture then we take this
v1 output and rectify it and shovel it
shove it through a scattering transform
essentially mixing model and shove it
into another v1 so this v2 module is
essentially exactly the same as this v1
module it's another set of motion energy
filters that uh apply to the output of
v1
then there's another scattering
transform which is just mixing the
different inputs and then that goes into
essentially another v1 model so the cool
thing about this model is it's kind of a
hypothesis that
as you develop through this visual
hierarchy each level of visual hierarchy
is essentially performing the same
operation as the earlier level is just
doing it on the rectified and remixed
output yes
mixing step there there's no
like convolutional magnet or it's like
all like
like individual like
pixel ones like one
there's a lot of weird com vocal
convolutions that go on here because you
have to deal with color and time and
space
uh but they're they're they're kind of
lost in the details on this level
uh so this is locally convolutional
um
what it has to preserve space obviously
right
so it's like for whatever it looks like
some kind of an arbitrary incision
why not three why not ten
oh well so it's it's an arbitrary
decision if you're not like you know a
neurophysiology insider right so this
model for v1 is like the canonical model
for v1 it's like the model everybody
believes
so um then we have two areas from v1 we
have v1 mostly projects in primates and
humans to v2 and v2 mostly projects to
v4
so down the ventral stream which is the
pattern recognition stream of your brain
so these
three layers that's like set by the
anatomy and then the only question is
what do we want to do in v2 and v4
and since nobody has any idea the
easiest thing is well let's just assume
that what happened when you as a primate
develops a new visual area is
essentially just did the same thing and
rerouted the inputs
so it looks it looks arbitrary but i
would rather than arbitrary i would
replace it with the word elegant
just because it sounds better
all right
and then we compare that to a vgg model
and the really cool thing about this is
you notice the number of parameters in
this model is 20 000.
if you take a pre pre-trained vgg model
and try to pitch these data you're
talking about you know
millions of parameters right
so um this model is way lower
dimensional
than taking proof trained features from
bgg way way way lower dimensional and
it's anatomically plausible every single
thing in this model we know how to build
out of neurons out of local circuit
elements and neurons
bgg
you know we have no idea how to build
that so that's that's kind of cool i
really like that for this reason
all right and um to make a long story
short since running out of time this
thing predicts really well
um this is vgg versus uh our model and
you can see
our model basically consistently gives
you better predictions
uh this prediction quality for these
neurons is about the same as the
predictions we used to have we already
uh used to get from primary visual
cortex so since everybody believes we
have a good model of prime visual cortex
by the criterion of prediction accuracy
we now have a good model of v4
the one thing i did want to mention here
is this plot this plot shows
the
prediction performance versus the amount
of data we have
and if we had saturated we would see
flat curves out here where we're not
improving prediction anymore you notice
none of these curves may be this red one
for this one neuron this is four
different neurons none of these curves
are flat meaning we don't have enough
data
we're already collecting 10 to the six
frames 100 times more data than anybody
else has and we still haven't saturated
our ability to fit this model even the
simple hce model
so this again
i keep repeating myself neuroscience is
data limited even when you do everything
you can to collect infinitely large data
sets that no other human will collect
you're still data limited
all right now we have a problem which is
that this model
is like two you know all these stages
are non-linear it's like hideous to try
to interpret what's going on here
there's there's no easy way to deal with
this and try to interpret it we can
interpret the anatomy we know what
computation is being performed but i
can't like go home and tell my wife oh
here's what v4 does which is what
everybody wants to know is it curvature
is it texture
is it color what is v4 doing right
everybody wants a
a story and i i can't give you a story
based on this model so the way we dealt
with this was we actually took a a trick
uh that we learned from ben you
um
and we developed we uh basically
determined through an iterative process
the optimal pattern that would drive all
the v4 neurons in our sample
and you can see these optimal patterns
here
on on these uh great this is i should
mention that these are
patterns right because we're we're uh
building a full space-time model but i'm
just marginalizing over time for these
plots
and so on the left you can see the v4
receptive fields which is just the
pattern that drives v4 neuron
on the right
is the
uh video frame that elicited the largest
response from the neuron in the
experiment
and in the middle they overlap
and you know some of these are pretty
remarkable like this is a prairie
pheasant
and you can see that this prairie
pheasant
perfectly matches this weird leaf-shaped
b4 receptive field and it was the
stimulus that drove the cell the highest
so you can use this kind of method to
try to interpret the v4 cells
but if you look at these receptive
fields
they're hideous no you can't look at
them and figure out what's what's going
on so this didn't really work
without further analysis so to do that
you got to do my channel reduction
take all 300 neurons and you project
them into i'm not going to go over this
in detail it's going to say what we did
you take your neurons you project them
into some subspace that's appropriate
like you can take the space marginal
space spatial embedding or a color
embedding you can take a global spatial
embedding or a local one whatever you
want and then once you get all the
neurons in this embedding then you can
just do the normal things everybody does
which is either pca
or cluster analysis or something like
that
and when we did this we found that
basically we could account for every
report of selectivity in v4 that
anybody's ever made over the past 40
years
okay so that's about it so um
i already went long so i'm not going to
belabor the point just want to say you
know neuroscience is data limited um
that limits that severely limits the
neural network uh and machine learning
applications we can we can use in
neuroscience all the machine learning
stuff that relates to regression still
works the deep modern work stuff doesn't
work so well but there are ways around
it it doesn't solve any interpretation
problems though the brain is complicated
and interpreting the brain is also
complicated thanks
[Applause]
before we take the pause uh to set up
for the panel any questions
quick questions yes
i have a yeah thanks for the very nice
talk i have a very quick question about
the receptive field analysis is it fair
to assume that there is only one optimum
that is relevant ah good question uh i
didn't have that slide in here so um
when you're estimating these these uh
predicted optimal patterns you know you
don't know that that's a convex
optimization problem there might be
multiple optimal patterns that that are
required so uh we actually for each
neuron we regenerated the optimal
patterns either 100 or a thousand times
i can't remember which and uh we looked
at the scatter for them and what we
found is most neurons have very compact
optima
which actually kind of surprised me a
few neurons have two or three optima but
the question isn't whether a neuron is
has a very compact optimum or a few
scatter points the question is how close
together are the predicted optima for
one neuron versus another neuron
and in that case they're all very far
apart so even when a neuron is a little
less compact than you might like it is
still very very different from all of
the other v4 neurons
do you think that that's the case
especially for v4 or is that a finding
that you find
i'm going to say that's a finding that's
general um
20 years ago now we showed that even v1
neurons for those of you who are vision
people you know vmware's primary visual
cortex is as dumb as a vega rocks
and the standard model of primary visual
cortex is a motion energy filter and
motion energy filters
they're all going to be very highly
correlated with each other but wouldn't
sorry
wouldn't you expect that uh higher brain
regions would have more optimal oh hang
on a sec so um well that yes but not in
the way you think yeah
so so in v1 if you consider the what is
known as the non-classical surround
which is a region around the motion
energy filter that modulates its its
responses
and you look at how that
non-classical complicated modulatory
response
affects the neurons response profile and
natural vision
it what it does is it decorates all the
motion energy filters
so v1 neurons are also very very
decorated with each other because of
this non-classical surround
as you progress farther up the visual
processing stream
the distinction between the classical
and non-classical surround kind of
disappears and neurons just become more
complicated
uh and they still retain this property
of being very very different from one
another now your question is well if i'm
in prefrontal cortex say someplace
really spooky where nobody has any idea
what's happening up there um are those
neurons do they have local
contact optima or distributed optimal
and my response would be they have
distributed optima because of attention
so
attention and learning have
an effect that is directly proportional
to the distance of the layer of the
neural network from
the uh motor and perceptual
surfaces
so if you are if you uh think about your
eyeball you know those neurons are just
always doing the same thing if you look
at v1 which is only two synapses up in
the eyeball um those neurons are almost
always doing the same thing
if you look at v4 which is the area that
i described today the attention has
about a 15 effect on neurons responses
if you look in the tip of the anterior
pole
those neurons are completely modulated
by attention they can be completely
switched on and off in prefrontal cortex
a dog neuron becomes a cat neuron or uh
learning to drive neuron or anything the
prefrontal cortex is very very very
flexible so if you if you think about
attention states and learning and top
down control then these neurons have
many many many
is it optima
same thing as plasticity or attention
modular plasticity plus this can also
happen for other reasons
well i have opinions about this but um
since this isn't my field take it with a
grain of salt
my personal feeling is that attention
is essentially just the the shortest
term version of plasticity right that is
that is uh sort of top down under your
control uh and basically learning is
just
the time integral of attention if you
attempt to something a lot over time
that becomes learning the temporary
changes
in the network become more permanent
because of repetition
and there's a lot of
evidence to suggest that's probably true
thanks
thanks a lot jack um so if you want get
up walk around for two or three minutes
at mo